frank lukat herzlich willkommen ja heute
meine damen und herren zu einem neuen
video auf meinem kanal mit zelt die
sandra und mir mit luca wir machen heute
nämlich gemeinsam ein gericht
entscheiden wann ich wollte spannend
halten wir machen einen nicht daten
challenge wunsch ich habe dafür ein
video ausgesucht und zwar dass hier
deutsche - part leute irgendwas
allerdings ist es nichts dass wir eine
bestrafung für uns selbst haben wenn
jemand von uns lacht sondern hier wird
graf
wir bestrafen mein neues handy und zwar
seht ihr schon diese hülle hierhin ist
von rainer schild und ihr seht doch
schon oben eingeblendet werbevideo denn
das heutige video ist mal wieder
freundlich unterstützt worden von rainer
schild und zwar an die mir gesagt luca
mach was du möchtest
die leute sind mega cool bahrain und ich
durfte mir irgendwas ausdenken was ich
machen möchte mit dem handy deswegen
habe ich mir überlegt dass gebäuden
haben wieder abend video mit mir macht
weil ich mir die ganze person in ganz
deutschland auf der ganzen welt ich
erzähler wegen ganzer klappen
ich habe hier ein glas vorbereitet und
in diesem glas sind sieben verschiedene
stellen denen dieses handy
entgegentreten muss beispielsweise handy
im treppenhaus hin fallen lassen
mit einem skateboard was händler mit dem
hammer ist nicht ausschlagen
also wenn jemand von uns beiden lacht
dann muss die person diese challenge
machen bei der allerdings nicht wir
leiden sondern dass handys hab ich sagen
noch erklärt und ich würd sagen wir
starten mit dem video hattest du dir
wohl aber dann fiel die erste challenge
raus also das hier ist das erste ding
was andere aus gesundheitlichen jemanden
anrufen und dabei das handy rum werfen
und den anderen fragen ob man ihnen dich
noch hört ok also wir rufen jetzt jemand
an und du musst dabei die so tun als ob
sie gerade bereit
[Gelächter]
damit können sie auch schon spazieren
fahren hier also das natürlich war sie
gerade fahren wirklich dieses buch
fordert auch die presse geflogen und
hatten schon gesagt ich kann noch kein
handy so leid an tut mir ist die
challenge von sammer sich wieder vorne
mit hammer auf die rückseite vom handy
schwein das kann ich nicht das kann ich
nicht
nico sind minimal leben anschlag einfach
ein bisschen leicht drauf ich muss ja
nicht zu glauben machen wenn du angst
hast du kannst ja so ein bisschen auf
die rückseite dass man auch sagen muss
also die höhen sind natürlich die halten
so was aus damit wird ihr auch rein
geschrieben werden gehen natürlich auch
aber das ist jetzt auch nichts was man
richtig macht ja keiner der sich ein
handy kaufen herauf das ist ja das
klingt also wir würden jetzt niemals
irgendwie kein mensch wird läuft kommt
eben darauf zu haben
aber okay da ist schon noch drüber
sprechen
ja das ist wohl vom dreck vom verband
als sinnvoll
ich bin nicht dollar aber es wird noch
zehn arbeiter jetzt system mit dem sich
alles noch ok weiter nation army gration
hintergrund gedacht dass damit ihr
hinter sich habe zuerst gedacht das
heißt ich ziehe mir jetzt hier die
dritte challenge raus und hier steht
drauf darauf rumspringen mit schuhen
mitschüler auf mehr in die rumspringen
also eine freude wenn sie jetzt schon
nicht richtig angezogen ich weiß war das
handy hat mich aufgrund kein problem und
auch rückseite der kamera herum
gesprungen und und also handy geht noch
und kamera geht auch noch alles was mein
trommelfell fliegt
nutzen sie also wirklich die nächste
challenge von sandra basketball im
papierkorb haben wir im ersten video
schon kurz gemacht
na also auch jetzt spiele wieder
basketball mit diesem hätten also
sammelt nächste challenge ist ja hier
die basketball challenge von daher habe
ich würde sagen machen das einfach mal
hier wirklich die man das handy also du
musst jetzt die nur einmal treffen sagte
basketball ist
getroffen hat es gut nichts nicht was
die rapper von müssen wir da weg läuft
okay wir noch ein bisschen weiter weg
juni schon wieder getroffen
doch was ist denn los ist hat eine
knappe mehrheit alles andere alter
was kannst du flammen wer kennt diese
kleine kinder diesem christlichen könig
sandra bisher waren politiker wenn sie
sich drauf geht oder so kann es ja auch
gleich damit die zeitung setzen sich
richtig pizza weiter mit dem ich lachen
video aber ist das so warum ist das für
alle vier jahre warum weiß ich ganz
genau
sandra hat und ich mal was gesagt
privileg barak will wissen was überhaupt
sagt jetzt hallo hallo was machen sagen
andere hatte ich einen nicht mitlachen
können
das ist ein gesponsertes video wir
müssen uns auch professionell und seriös
verhalten und gegenüber rein und wir
kommen da rein will deinen gegnern
vorletzte challenge versteht da handy
fallen lassen
von treppe ok ja ganz simpel handy
einfach von der treppe fallen lassen
sondern sind darüber auf der treppe und
sondern ich das handy jetzt wieder von
oben hier einfach unter
circa drei meter würde ich sagen einfach
wir kommen traditionell das ist so
könnte ganz einfach zurück okay das war
blöd dass wir direkt auf dem bildschirm
nichts passiert ist oh mein gott
was machen eigentlich müssen wir letzte
challenge zusammen machen alter das
alter
ich war die ganze zeit sinnvoller und
der kapitel zum lachen aber gut ok die
letzten chips handy im treppenhaus
fallen lassen
also ja dann dass wir beide einfach
jeder einmal das handy haken auffallen
das ding ist halt der boten die mir da
wo du bist so holz nächste deshalb auch
so ein bisschen weich habe würde ich mal
sagen weil er hier ist halt so
deshalb suche ich tag hat der boden hier
ist nichts was nicht
ich weiß auch noch mal ein bisschen aus
der höheren entfernung hin ja nix nix
ich hab es hat sich so gar nicht
angewiesen ja auch so was andere städte
würden dann doch nicht das heutige video
an der stelle allerdings auch beenden
danke nochmal meine spieler für das
heutige genau vor keine ganz anderer
folge mir gern schaut auch gern bereit
vorbei danke auf jeden fall an rainer
schild dass ihre mitglieder so unfassbar
viele höhlen zugesendet hat und dass
innerhalb und endlich machen nicht nur
für das iphone sondern auch für das
google fordern die mir geschickt also
für android geräte auch für smart watch
es auch unter anderem apple watch auch
fürs ipad machen die höhlen also nicht
nur für das neue iphone das sie hat sehr
wenig gesehen haben alles mögliche
mitgemacht einem skateboard oder vater
leider nicht ganz geklappt aber mit
schon drauf angesprungen im treppenhaus
haben sich aus drei metern höhe fallen
lassen wir haben mit mama
draufgeschlagen kranke sachen gemacht
also die höhen sind auf jeden fall sehr
resistent was das alles an geht dann
kann rainer schild dort gern bei den auf
der website vorbei
[Musik]